did Kim rip the Marilyn dress at the Met
Ball did you help Kim release her sex
tape am I your favorite child Kris
Jenner in the hot seat on The Late Late
Show with James Corden yeah it was nutty
the mama jerk taking a lie detector test
and answering burning questions about
her famous fam did Kim rip the Marilyn
dress at the Met Ball
no no
true
see we're clearing everything up today I
like this game and while we're talking
about Kim did you help Kim release her
sex tape
it's okay no
no
of course it's true
but leave it to Kylie Jenner the
youngest of Chris's six kids to ask the
question every sibling wants to know am
I your favorite child
yes
true
from Chris's youngest to her oldest I'm
proud of all my kids Kourtney Kardashian
and her over-the-top PDA with hubby
Travis Barker yeah they like to make out
a lot like a lot a lot do you think
Travis and Courtney's PDA is too much
once in a while
[Music]
oh
but hang on what does that mean yeah do
you think it's too much
once in a while is too much like once in
a while you know a little bit goes a
long way
I'm trying to say it as nice as possible
Chris doesn't hold back when addressing
this viral moment though I definitely am
not a good cutter so don't zoom in on me
has Kendall learned how to cut a
cucumber
true it's absolutely true now this isn't
the first time Chris has been put to the
polygraph test I definitely think that
doing a lie detector test is over the
top dramatic but if it makes everybody
see that I'm not lying or not being
shady then so be it yeah that's
thermometer back in 2012 when she had a
different favorite kid
Kim your favorite daughter yes
[Music]
fast forward a decade and we're keeping
up with the Kardashian Jenner family in
a whole new way you never know what's
gonna happen they're now documenting
their lives on their Hulu series The
Kardashians which returns for season two
on September 22nd and seems like per
usual there's a lot to keep up with
we're back in case you missed us oh my
gosh life is good I have a new boyfriend
I'm just having a really good time I
made a baby this is my 11th grandchild I
love that the episodes are more a little
bit documentary style and I think that
you have a real insight into what the
girls are doing not only you know what
you see in the press or whatever but
what's really happening behind the
scenes just so interesting to see it
from the inside out and really get a
glimpse of what happens and how they all
balance what they do
foreign